mathématiques français géographie ou
langue étrangère faire ses devoirs avant
de rentrer à la maison c'est l'objectif
des études surveillées à montigny le
bretonneux ce dispositif existe depuis
2003 et emploie plus d'une trentaine de
vacataires pour surveiller les enfants
trois fois par semaine entre 17 et 18
heures ils sont là pour assurer
effectivement la surveillance de l'étude
pendant l'heure ils sont responsables
des élèves et ils doivent s'assurer que
les élèves fassent bien leurs devoirs
pendant sept heures va donc cesser de
l'accompagnement scolaire mais c'est pas
donné de voir la différence donc entre
aide aux devoirs et études surveillées
la réalité elle est plus complexe
difficile de ne pas répondre à des
élèves en difficulté
je vois pas la possibilité qu'il y en a
un qui me demande est ce que tu peux
m'aider pauline et je peux pas lui
répondre non moi je suis là pour te
sauver jeu je sais que je peux l'aider
alors je me fais après la présentation
de l'allemand je pourrai pas les ai déjà
mais finalement donc là j'essaie d'entre
eux c'est bien mais les plus petits pour
la lecture je les fais toujours avec eux
la dictée mots je le fais aussi avec eux
chaque semaine 900 élèves profit des
études surveillées à montigny le
bretonneux un accompagnement utile pour
les parents et qui plaît aux enfants
j'aime bien puisque tu fais tes devoirs
et après tu as pas faire deux fois raté
mais tu peux jouer parce que j'aime
c'est rester avec mes copains fin mes
devoirs tranquille et lire des livres
mois pour faire mes devoirs quand je
suis tout seul chez moi va je trouve que
c'est plus difficile pour réviser que
quand je suis avec mes amis on va donc
je préfère être à l'étude que tout seul
chez moi
fort de son succès le dispositif des
études surveillées est proposée sur
l'ensemble des 15 écoles élémentaires de
montigny le bretonneux